[Captioned by Judy V. at Y Translator]
In today's video, we'll be
revisiting an experiment
where we combine super glue
with hot borax solution.
We'll try a few different
methods of combining the two,
and see how it reacts.
[Music]
Not too long ago,
I had an experiment
where I took a balloon full of super glue,
submerged it underneath
some hot borax solution,
and then I popped the balloon,
and that looked really cool.
It sort of exploded
and solidified all at once,
kind of reminding me of
a giant kernel of popcorn.
Today, what we're going to do is
revisit that with some better lighting,
a square walled tank,
so you can see everything better,
and we're going to try some of
the different ways to mix the two
that were suggested in the
comments of the previous video.
Here's the basic idea.
We've got a 10 gallon fish tank
full of hot borax solution,
and we're going to try
combining it with super glue
in pretty much every way
we can come up with.
Before we start pouring large
quantities of super glue into this tank,
I do want to try a few experiments with
other methods of combining these two.
So we'll try making some super glue
into some plain borax with no water.
We'll try mixing it into
a cold borax solution.
We'll add some super glue to
hot water with no borax in it.
We'll see if adding the alcohol ink
seems to change the reaction time
at all in the hot borax solution.
We'll try loading some of
our super glue into a squirt gun,
and a large plastic syringe,
and we'll see you how they react.
[Music]
Super glue coming
in contact with the borax.
I would say it solidified
pretty much instantly.
Let's try just another
little squirt right here.
See if does the same thing.
I'm gonna try and poke it with my
finger just a little bit faster this time.
[Music]
Yep, that is cured.
Now, we have evidence that borax will
solidify super glue just right on contact,
which helps explain why the hot borax
solution solidifies superglue so quickly.
[Music]
Adding in some
borax to our cool water,
now with the borax
dissolved into the water,
water does cause super glue
to harden all on its own,
and borax makes it harden very quickly.
So, I expect that this will still cause
our super glue to harden quite quickly,
although not as fast as the hot solution.
That was pretty neat.
[Music]
So that definitely does go quickly.
Also makes kind of a neat noise.
As a comparison, now,
here is our hot borax solution.
[Music]
So it works pretty well
in cool borax solution,
but hot borax solution is
even faster and more reactive.
That's why we like to
keep it nice and warm.
It is possible that this has more
to do with my squirting technique
than the temperature.
But I also think that
the hot borax solution
makes for a fluffier plastic
than the cool borax solution.
A popular request was to see
what would happen if we squirted,
instead of the super glue into the solution,
the solution into the super glue.
So I'm now filling this cup
partway with super glue.
We'll use a syringe and squirt our
hot borax solution into the glue.
First couple drips.
That was more dripping in than I wanted.
[Music]
All right.
Now, I'm just going to squirt
quite a bit in all at once.
[Music]
We've got a tank full of hot water.
Let's add in some borax.
We tried loading some
super glue into a squirt gun,
but the squirt gun wouldn't squirt.
I think some of the superglue must
have gummed up the work so quickly
that it wasn't really pumping
it out to the nozzle.
In the last video, there were some
comments saying that the alcohol
that I used in the ink to dye the super glue
might actually affect the reaction time.
I'm gonna do a little bit
of a side-by-side test of
super glue without ink,
and super glue with ink
to see if it seems that it's
going any faster or slower.
[Music]
There's some super glue with no dye.
That is plenty of dye right there.
[Music]
Got a good red color super glue going on.
If there is a difference in the
reaction speed, it's quite minimal.
That is polymerizing very quickly.
[Music]
It's cool how organic
this ends up looking.
Like this looks like a creature
or coral, or something like that.
It doesn't look like something
that was just manufactured.
It kind of looks more
like something that grew.
We did discover by accident that
if you add too much alcohol ink,
it actually causes a
reaction with the super glue.
It heats up, bubbles, and polymerizes,
solidifying quickly, and
kind of dangerously, actually.
We've seen what plane super glue
going down into the borax solution does,
but what happens if the super glue
is coated on something else?
Putting on a black glove
over another pair of gloves,
because well, two reasons.
One, I don't want the super glue
to accidentally get on my skin,
and these other gloves are longer,
and two, the borax
solution is warm enough
that it's uncomfortable down inside,
and I think that the super glue
reacting will get even warmer.
So this is a heat barrier around my hand.
Here it goes.
Three. Two. One.
It was quick, but it wasn't very extreme.
It was such a thin coating of
super glue that for the most part,
it just polymerized into a thin film.
[Music]
It's glued shut.
One.
[Music]
That might be about the
quickest and strangest way
to go through 16 fluid
ounces of super glue,
but it does look really cool.
It's a fun reaction to try.
It's a fun reaction to watch,
and uh, the result is really entertaining.
If there's any other experiments
you would like to see us try
along these same lines,
or just with Superglue in general,
let us know down in the comments.
Try and be a little bit more creative
than put it in a vacuum chamber,
put in the furnace,
put it in liquid nitrogen,
put glow sticks fluid in it.
That's not the kind of ideas we're looking.
I came up with those all on my
own as soon as I thought of trying
to use super glue for stuff.
I want to see something new.
Guys, we've got more for you to see.
That box up at the top will
transport you directly to our last video,
and you should go check that out.
The box at the bottom will show you what
YouTube thinks you should be watching next,
and if you hit this bomb in the middle,
you'll be subscribed to the channel
so you never miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.